[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Grégoire cuvier auteur
et metteur en scène du théâtre de cher
bonjour bonjour si vous êtes invité
aujourd'hui c'est pour parler de votre
spectacle les fleurs de macchabée vous
avez notamment présenté le spectacle à
Corbeil-Essonnes ou encore prochainement
au théâtre Coluche à plaisir c'est un
spectacle de 9h avec entracte comment en
êtes-vous arrivé à créer un spectacle de
9h
un peu par hasard en fait c'était pas il
y a pas eu d'intention de départ de
créer un grand spectacle il y avait une
histoire qui cheminait en moi depuis
quelques années et puis bon après au gré
des aléas de la création et et du
confinement aussi qui a eu son incidence
là-dessus parce qu'il a tout d'un coup
donné aussi une plage de temps assez
élargi pour travailler sur sur
l'écriture
et donc cette histoire en fait j'ai
commencé j'ai travaillé pendant
plusieurs mois au moment du confinement
sur d'une part la documentation parce
que écrire un polar mine de rien ça
demande
voilà de s'emparer d'un univers auquel
on connaît rien donc entre les lectures
de cours de droit et les entretiens avec
des policiers en service avec des
d'un commandant de police notamment avec
lequel j'ai eu beaucoup plusieurs
entretiens des médecins des travailleurs
sociaux
parce que voilà au bout d'un commençant
à travailler sur sur le polar je me suis
rendu compte que les cours de droit que
je lisais parce que je ressentais ce
besoin de comprendre de quoi je parlais
mais les cours de droit que je disais
correspondaient pas à la réalité enfin à
la réalité à la fiction aux fiction que
je disais au polar que je disais j'avais
besoin un petit peu de comprendre
comment ça marchait donc il y a eu
plusieurs mois de documentation et
parallèlement à ce documentation la
structuration d'un récit qui était
l'histoire que je voulais raconter
depuis longtemps
dont les racines étaient l'envie de de
sortir de la figure du monstre quand il
y a souvent quand il y a des faits
divers qui a des meurtres ou des
criminels on a une tendance
sociale sur logique politique médiatique
à
créer des figures de monstres vraiment
dire à mettre aux bandes de la société
aux banc de l'humanité les criminels et
moi ça m'intéressait de ramener dans le
giron de l'humanité ces personnes là
donc ça c'était le point de départ
et donc cette cette structuration du
récit parallèlement à cette
documentation c'est fait pendant
plusieurs mois et ensuite j'ai consacré
à moi entier à temps plein vraiment de
manière très studieuse à écrire 40
heures par semaine 8 heures par jour les
dialogues à partir de la structure que
j'avais que j'avais construite pendant
ce premier temps de d'écriture et
je suis arrivé au bout du premier acte
avec attaque quatre actes dans la pièce
et arriver au bout du premier acte je
vois que j'ai écrit 76 pages de de
théâtre et je me dis mais ça me paraît
beaucoup j'ai regardé dans mes autres
textes dans les autres pièces que j'ai
écrit et je vois que la plus longue qui
devait faire une heure 45 faisait 54
pages et là je suis d'accord ok c'est un
gros bébé je suis beau je continue je
suis continué je suis allé au bout de la
pièce comme ça
et puis je les fais lire je l'ai fait
lire à des gens à des gens de théâtre à
des gens qui étaient pas des gens de
théâtre notamment aux personnes aux
commandants de police au traverss
sociaux aux gens avec qui j'avais
travaillé et puis j'ai recueilli des
impressions et
et déjà au moment de la lecture les gens
me disaient mais en fait on commence à
lire on n'arrive pas à s'arrêter les
gens disaient bah merci j'ai commencé à
lire à 20h je me suis couché à 2h du
matin parce que j'ai pas réussi à
m'arrêter les gens plongés dans ce récit
là et je dis ok d'accord c'est bien
quelque chose qui marche bien dans ce
récit et en fait il y avait rien à
acheter tout à garder finalement dans
dans ces 9h et ben complètement c'est en
fait c'est de entre ce cette première
écriture alors il y a un énorme travail
préalable vraiment à la mise en dialogue
c'est un gros travail de structuration
mais effectivement j'ai tout gardé il y
a eu des petits ajustements d'écriture
après au gré du travail avec les acteurs
au plateau mais il y a pas eu de coupe
j'ai pas j'ai pas enlevé de saigne il y
a aucune scène qui a été coupée tout a
été gardé
après c'est vrai je voyais bien que le
spectacle allait être énorme ce qu'on
dit 9h mais c'est 9h avec les entracte
venir mais c'est vrai que sur scène il y
a 6h30 7h de spectacle voilà avec les
entraxes ça fait 9 heures quoi ça fait
une grande aventure
mais les entraxes sont importants aussi
permet vraiment des respirations et on
replonge dans le récit et ça bon après
je pourrais peut-être en parler tout à
l'heure mais c'est vrai que quand on
voit que les gens ils vont au moment des
entraxes sont ils sont très excités par
le récit et ils ont qu'une envie c'est
d'y retourner dans la salle en fait les
entrées leur paraissent trop long c'est
une façon justement de les faire
participer les les les spectateurs
justement pendant les entrailles peuvent
échanger un petit peu et voir faire un
retour alors c'était pas moi j'avais
jamais fait un spectacle comme ça
j'avais jamais eu même un entrac dans
mes spectacles avant qui était dans des
formats beaucoup plus classiques mais ce
qu'on a pu constater là on a joué déjà
quatre fois le spectacle depuis sa
création à la Scène nationale de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines en décembre
ce qu'on constate et moi je trouve ça
très beau c'est que les gens se
rencontrent dans le théâtre on voit les
gens dans les lignes de spectateurs se
rencontrent on voit parce qu'on a des
quelques amis qui viennent nous voir et
puis on rencontre qui il se rend compte
entre eux ils rencontrent d'autres
spectateurs et qui parlent effectivement
de leurs impressions de leurs intuitions
de ce qu'ils ont vécu il y a vraiment un
un moment de vie qui se passe dans le
théâtre et pendant les entrailles tous
les gens échangent entre eux et
effectivement sont appelés par cette
enquête dont on vit de comprendre ce qui
se passe et ça les amène à échanger
entre il y avait un vrai moment de de
vie comme ça en commun et ça ça c'était
un petit peu quand j'ai monté le
spectacle c'était effectivement je me
suis dit ça c'est plus qu'un spectacle
c'est un moment de vie à partager avec
d'autres gens face à une histoire et
puis et puis c'est pas que face à une
histoire c'est c'est ça aussi la beauté
du théâtre c'est que c'est un peu je dis
beaucoup dit aussi c'est comme une série
Netflix mais au théâtre mais finalement
je crois que c'est plus fort qu'une
série Netflix qu'on regarderait dans une
journée parce que les acteurs sont là
ils sont de chair et d'os ils sont sur
scène on vit avec eux quelque chose de
très vivant il y a une interaction enfin
nous on sent les toutes les
représentations qu'on a fait je dis oh
parce que je c'est la première fois
aussi je joue dans la pièce j'ai un
petit rôle
du coup je suis très content de partager
avec les acteurs cette expérience de au
plateau mais vraiment on sent bien que
sur scène on vit avec la salle on sent
que la salle elle est avec nous qui est
une respiration commune comme ça et
qu'on les emmène et et c'est un moment
de vie très intense très très fort et
des deux côtés de la barre alors
justement on a parlé un petit peu de
donc des rencontres que vous avez fait
pour construire cette pièce du projet on
n'a pas parlé de la pièce en elle-même
quel est l'intrigue des fleurs de
macchabée alors c'est une pièce de 9h et
c'est un peu on va dire il y a plusieurs
intrigue plusieurs intrigues qui
s'entrelacent mais au cœur de cette
histoire et à une capitaine de police
qui s'appelle Margot Deveron qui
qui commet un faux pas à être travail à
Marseille comme il faut pas à Marseille
qui lui vaut d'être muté voilà quand il
y a des incidents en police des fois bon
voilà on
on mute la personne rapidement pour
l'extraire du milieu ou elle a fait faux
pas quoi je reste un peu ambigueux
exprès ce que j'ai pas non plus envie de
spoiler la pièce et donc Margaux devront
se retrouve muté dans une halle qui est
habituée à des affaires brûlantes à
Marseille ils se retrouvent à l'unité de
police judiciaire de Tours qui est la
préfecture d'un Dreux Loire qui est une
ville de taille assez modeste par
rapport à Marseille par rapport aux
grandes agglomérations et
elle arrive là mais concomitamment à son
arrivée de faits divers hors du commun
surgissent on découvre le corps d'une
inconnue sur les bords de la Loire sur
l'îlocar et une jeune fille disparaît
et c'est deux faits divers viennent un
petit peu voilà
du coup faire que que l'enquêtrice
sevronnait qu'elle est va prendre toute
sa valeur parce qu'elle arrive dans une
équipe
un peu un peu fragile on va dire des
gens un peu éprouvés aussi par une
épreuve récente le l'ancien chef de leur
unité s'est suicidé quelques temps avant
et elle arrive dans une équipe un peu
ébranlée et tout son savoir-faire va
prendre son sens avec justement avec ces
deux faits divers qui vont s'avérer lier
ça je peux vous le dire et puis mais
peut-être aussi plus que ça voilà c'est
ces deux affaires vont prendre une
dimension complètement inattendue au
départ de cette histoire
et
voilà je crois que c'est pas mal
qui est cet inconnu retrouvée sur
l'îlocar et
comment pourquoi a disparu et où est
cette jeune fille de 12 ans qui a
disparu voilà c'est deux les deux heures
plusieurs intrigues finalement qui sont
entremêlent même à l'intérieur de
l'histoire mais qui se regroupe
finalement un peu un peu tout à la fin
parce que c'est aussi l'histoire de
Margaux devront parce que un polar c'est
quoi c'est pas qu'une enquête en fait
c'est comment en tant qu'être humain on
se retrouve confronté à des choses qui
ne dépassent notre entendement comment
c'est c'est un prétexte le polar c'est
un prétexte à plonger un petit peu dans
dans la complexité des humanités qui
nous composent et c'est aussi donc
l'histoire de Margot devron qui se
retrouve elle mutée qui est maire d'une
jeune fille qui à l'âge de la disparu
aussi donc souvent quand j'ai travaillé
dans mon cours de mon travail de
documentation je me suis rendu compte
que dans dans l'imaginaire policier il y
a cette histoire de l'affaire de leur
vie l'affaire qui les ébranle qui
vraiment les
les bouleverse et
très souvent pour pas dire toujours
l'affaire qui bouleverse en inquiéter
c'est une affaire qui va avoir une
résonance avec sa vie personnelle et
souvent j'ai remarqué que il parle
d'affaires où les victimes
on lâche de leurs enfants de
quelqu'un de très proche de là on a
cette résonance là avec Margaux devront
c'est aussi et c'est l'histoire de de
l'unité de police judiciaire qui est
branlée par le suicide d'un délai par
l'arrivée de quelqu'un qui arrive
d'ailleurs et puis qui a qui a des
galons aussi peut-être leur on va
surtout pas trop en dire pour ceux qui
veulent justement découvrir ça se passe
le 3 juin donc au théâtre au théâtre
Coluche merci beaucoup Grégoire cuvier
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensation on
peut retrouver plus d'informations sur
le site théâtre de share.com ou sur
insta et Facebook donc je l'ai dit le 3
juin à plaisir pour ceux qui voudraient
découvrir cette pièce de 9h avec
entracte et pour revoir ou réécouter
cette émission rendez-vous sur notre
site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]